platonic oh God I wish it means that you
are just platonic I don't know where the
word comes from Plato Plato only ever
got friendzoned
it was really fun being back on set
collaborating we fun to work together
it was part of the pitch yeah it wasn't
like guess what they cast roads platonic
there's a TV show about a man and a
woman who were very good friends and
they haven't spoken in years and then
they reconnect there's a re-emergence
into each other's lives they're very
different points Sylvia is a mother of
three will was mommy's best friend like
an ex no just a friend with benefits no
oh what will is a newly single guy and
he runs a brewery she's gone for five
years and now she's back yes can't be
friends with a girl that is absolutely
not true the whole movie When Harry Met
Sally is dedicated to proving the fact
that you can be friends with a woman no
well that's a bad example Perry Mary
Sally girlfriends
it's so rare that there is that kind of
dynamic on television and just really
funny can't we just have fun like we
used to have what are we gonna do what
are we gonna do for fun
[Music]
oh
whoa
send me the invoice
[Music]
don't look at my ass unless you want to
get hypnotized with all due respect I do
not just go nothing between the sheets
nothing between the sheets that is the
fundamental Bedrock of their
relationship
yes yes I am
but no funny business it was easy to
kill any sexual tension between us